[Music]
data is often scattered in many places
you may store customer tables in
bigquery while your sales tables live in
cloud sql
nonetheless it is important to be able
to join these tables together when
performing
analysis cloud sql federation from
bigquery enables you to analyze data
residing in cloud sql in real time
without copying or moving data it
supports both mysql and postgres
instances in cloud sql after an initial
one-time setup you can write queries
referencing connected cloud sql tables
using a special sql function called
external query
let's walk through the steps to complete
the initial setup and then run an
example query
step 1. enable the bigquery connection
service
start in the cloud console and select
the project that includes the cloud sql
instance that you want to query
if you would like to start with the same
cloud sql instance we are using in this
quick start
you may pause the video and first follow
the code lab linked in the description
below
in this project you will need to have
both the bigquery admin role and the
cloud sql editor or cloud sql admin role
use the left-hand menu to click on apis
and services
click enable apis and services and then
search for bigquery connection api
click to enable step two configure
public ip connectivity for your cloud
sql instance
use the search bar to navigate to cloud
sql
click the instance name to open its
details page
select the connections tab
make sure the public ip checkbox is
marked
while public ipconnectivity is not as
secure as private ip only
your instance will remain inaccessible
from the public internet because you
have not provided an authorized address
however this will make it possible to
connect to your instance from bigquery
click save if you made changes step 3
set up the cloud sql database connection
in bigquery
use the search bar to navigate to
bigquery click
add data and select external data source
now you will provide the details needed
to establish the connection resource
choose your database type in this case
mysql
give the connection id a name you will
use this identifier when you are
referencing the resource from a query
the location you choose must be
compatible with your cloud sql region
and your intended use within bigquery
since our cloud sql database is located
in u.s central 1
we will need to use the us multi-region
location
more information on location
compatibility is linked in the
description below
enter the full name of the cloud sql
instance in the format of project id
colon location id colon instance id
you can find the instance id on the
details page of the cloud sql instance
you want to query
for database name enter the name of the
database
then enter the username and password for
the database
note if these same user credentials are
valid for other databases in the
particular cloud sql instance
the connection will also allow queries
over those additional databases through
the same connection resource
click create connection you'll see the
connection populate in the left-hand nav
step 4 grant permission to connection
users
select the connection in the left-hand
nav and click share connection
enter the user's address and select
bigquery connection user which gives the
user the ability to query with the
connection
alternatively you can give a user the
role bigquery connection admin which
allows them to create
manage and share connections in addition
to using them in queries
now that we've completed the initial
setup let's see how to write queries
over tables in the connected database
our first query joins the employees and
salaries tables
both in the cloud sql database to
analyze the average salary by year of
hire
querying over the external connection
requires the external query function
the syntax of this function requires the
connection id which you can find by
selecting the connection
and looking in the details next is a
string of the query in the external
databases sql dialect
note that when querying a cloud sql
connection bigquery cannot predict the
amount of data to be processed
you will only know after you run your
query when you hit run the query is
executed in the external database and
cloud sql
next let's see an example of joining a
bigquery table with a table in your
cloud sql database
we have taken a snapshot of the salaries
table and loaded it into bigquery so
that we can show joining data across
bigquery and cloud sql resources
the example query includes three parts
external query is used to select the
employee number and hire date fields
from the cloud sql employees table
then the results are joined by employee
number with the salaries table which is
located in bigquery
finally the query calculates the average
salary for employees in each higher year
click run and after the query completes
you'll see the same results
the cost of your queries will follow
standard bigquery pricing either on
demand based on the amount of data
processed or as part of a flat rate
model if that is applicable to your
organization
you've just seen how to set up a cloud
sql connection and
query the connection using the external
query function for more information on
federated queries with cloud sql
please navigate to the documentation
linked below happy analyzing
[Music]